basketball has changed from
um
like it's not so much that chess board
anymore
it's checkers it's not greg popovich
anymore no it's not chess it's checking
it's checkers it's king me it is this is
the most it's the arms race it's kings
me right
but it's it's the reason why i say that
is because there is literally no thought
involved like
damian lillard is going to come down
here full speed and jump and just shoot
yeah he's going to shoot a 40-footer if
you step up that means he's going to the
basket all the way to the basket but
this is not a foot race immediately if
he can't get it it's to cj and it's the
same thing immediate action like
i think that the pa like if you go look
at older games you go watch the game in
the 80s
they sprint the ball up the sideline
they throw the ball to the corner to
flatten the defense they throw it back
up and then they throw it into the post
yeah you go to the 90s they took that
same formula except they threw a shooter
into the corner
and then tossed it straight down to the
post and the post didn't have to be a
big man but it's all to [ __ ] up the
rotations of the defense right
now
the [ __ ] up is they bring in a ball
screen
they're not even going to the corner to
flatten the defense or throw it in
they're keeping you way out
so it's like when the game-changing
dynamic like that when you're watching
this [ __ ] i don't know how other people
process it but like i didn't had to sit
there and like watch you know i played i
got to play whoever the best player is
so i get a lot of this
watching how they coming down and being
like bro their point of attack yeah you
were kind of the guy who defended the
best player on the other hand how to
deal with that right that was what you
saw i'm looking at every scheme like
i'm like bro like i've literally made it
to like you got to think my first year
in the league i had to guard all those
in-game possessions so i'm used to at
the end of the game i'm about to have to
go to the post and deal with so much
contact and
drops and back doors and [ __ ] that i got
to deal with in this mode and it was
like
also when you got drafted that wasn't
the best like you were probably the best
defensive like at least one of the best
defensive players on that knicks team
like
not no no no no no no no audio i was the
best defensive player i mean listen i
don't want to disrespect your other
teammates no you could do it they were
they weren't great i mean you know you
could do it if you want to you know
nobody yeah at the end of the game when
they go down you had to pick up a lot of
slack that's what i'm saying
i mean i had to pick up slack it's just
it's one of them moves like when you get
to the nba you start realizing these
grown ass men this ain't
oh man mellow doesn't know how to guard
people is nah fan iman you guard him i'm
finna score 40. yeah
that's this grow man [ __ ] this is jr
literally a come out there and be like
tape i don't
rook handle that i'm not chasing him
i don't care what the i don't care what
the
the plays uh you know the assignments
and i don't care you tired rook guard
him i'm tired i don't feel like guarding
it that's what j.r say and everybody
alright cool